NUMBERS AT THAT LEVEL.
WILL OUT OF 10 EVANGELICALS
STILL SUPPORT HIM.
THAT'S INCREDIBLE IN THE
FACE OF WHAT THEY HAVE BEEN
SEEING.
>> Laura: SO THE LEFT
THOUGHT THAT THEY WOULD PUSH
THE SEX NARRATIVE, DONALD
TRUMP.
>> THE NETWORKS WITH DOING
IT AROUND THE CLOCK.
>> Laura: IT IS NONSTOP.
THEY THOUGHT THAT WOULD
CRACK HIM.
THAT WOULD CRACK HIM.
CRACK HIS SUPPORT.
IT REMINDS ME OF THE BILLIE
BUSH TAPE CAME OUT.
THEY THOUGHT THAT WAS IT WE
STUCK A FORK IN HIM.
HE IS DONE.
AGAIN, THEY DON'T WANT TO
DEBATE TRUMP ON THE ISSUES.
THEY DO NOT WANT TO TALK
ISSUES.
THEY WANT TO DEMONIZE AND
ISOLATE HIM AND DESTROY HIM.
THAT'S THE LEFT'S TACTIC.
>> LOOK AT THIS PIECE OF
VIDEO.
THIS IS CNN.
THEY CONVENED A GROUP OF
EVANGELICAL WOMEN AND THEY
THOUGHT WELL, WE WILL RATTLE
THEM.
WE WILL PLAY SOME STORMY
DANIELS FOR THEM.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENED.
>> WHY WOULD SHE COME OUT
AND GIVE THIS INTERVIEW IF
SHE WASN'T TELLING THE
TRUTH?
>> MONEY.
>> AND MORE MONEY.
>> DO ANY -- BASED ON THIS
INTERVIEW, DO ANY OF YOU
BELIEVE THAT STORMY DANIELS
DID HAVE SEX WITH TRUMP?
>> I DON'T BELIEVE IT I
HAVEN'T SEEN ANY HARD PROOF.
>> BELIEVE THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
>> PICK HIM OVER HER.
>> OR A STRIPPER PORN STAR.
>> I GO WITH THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES.
>> THIS IS A PORN STAR.
WHY ARE WE GIVING IT ANY
CREDIBILITY?
>> Laura: WHY ARE THEY
STICKING BY HIM?
>> THEY ARE STICKING BY HIM
BECAUSE, REMEMBER, DURING
THE CAMPAIGN, I WENT OUT
POLLING PLACES AND
ENCOUNTERED A NUMBER OF
EVANGELICALS AND CATHOLICS
WHY IN THE LIGHT OF THE
BILLIE BUSH THING ARE YOU
VOTING FOR THIS MAN?
>> Laura: THAT'S RIGHT.
>> THEY SEWED WE BELIEVE HE
IS CHECK NOT ONLY ON
GOVERNMENT GONE AWAY WE
DIDN'T LIKE IT TO GO BUT ON
OUR CHURCHES THAT HAVE ALSO
GOTTEN VERY POLITICAL.
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES AND
CLIMATE CHANGE AND WE DON'T
AGREE WITH THAT THEY SAID.
THEY SEE THE PRESIDENT AS A
CHECK IN ALL THOSE AREAS.
LOOK AT THE AGENDA AND THE
RECORD HE HAS CHANGED AND
DROPPED THE OBAMACARE
REGULATIONS.
>> Laura: FUNDING PLANNED
PARENTHOOD THOUGH.
>> WELL, PLANNED PARENTHOOD.
>> Laura: THAT'S A BILLING
MISTAKE.
>> STOPPED THE FUNDING OF
PLANNED PARENTHOOD WHICH HE
PROMISED AND PROTECTIONS.
STILL WILLING TO GIVE HIM
THE BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT
ALSO FOR A MAN NOT
PARTICULARLY RELIGIOUS, HE
SPEAKS AND TALKS ABOUT GOD
WITH REGULATOR.
EVANGELICALS LIKE THAT.
>> Laura: I STILL REMEMBER
THE LIGHTING OF THE
CHRISTMAS TREE.
I HAVEN'T HEARD JESUS
MENTIONED THAT MUCH.
THAT WAS UNBELIEVABLE.
>> IT WAS A VERY HEART FELT.
>> Laura: RELIGIOUS.
WE ARE USED TO SAYING HAPPY
SEASONS GREETINGS.
>> SANTA CLAUS.
ALL ABOUT THE BABY IN THE
MANGER.
>> Laura: THE POPE SENT
EVERYONE OVER THE EDGE
THROUGH THIS INTERVIEW THAT
HE DID WITH 3-YEAR-OLD THE
ATHEIST.
>> ITALIAN NEWSPAPER 93
YEARS OLD.
HE HAS INTERVIEWED THE POPE
FIVE TIMES.
>> Laura: WHY IS THE POPE
GOING TO DO INTERVIEWS THINK
HE MIGHT CONVERT HIM.
>> CONVERT HIM AND FRIENDLY.
SEE THE WORLD POLITICALLY IN
THE SAME WAY.
LOOK, HE CLAIMED THE POPE
SAID HELL DOES NOT EXIST.
WE WILL PUT IT UP ON YOUR
SCREEN.
WHAT EXISTS IS THE
DISAPPEARANCE OF SINFUL
SOULS, I WON'T GO FURTHER
BECAUSE WE ARE RUNNING OUT
OF TIME.
>> Laura: THERE IT IS.
CAN YOU READ THE WHOLE
THING.
>> HELL DOES NOT EXIST.
WHAT EXIST U.S. IS THE
DISAPPEARANCE OF SINFUL
SOULS.
THEY ARE NOT PUNISHED.
THOSE WHO REPENT OBTAIN THE
FORGIVENESS OF GOD AND GO
AMONG THE RANKS OF THE SOULS
WHO CONTEMPLATE HIM.
THOSE WHO COULD NOT REPENT
THEREFORE CANNOT BE FORGIVEN
THEY DISAPPEAR.
NOW, AS CAN YOU IMAGINE, ALL
OF CHRISTIAN DOM WAS UP IN
ARMS WHEN THIS HEADLINE HIT
POPE SAYS HELL DOES NOT
EXIST.
>> Laura: GOOD FRIDAY THING.
>> THIS IS THE SECOND TIME
HE HAS CLAIMED THE POPE SAID
HELL DOES NOT EXIST.
>> Laura: ISN'T THAT THE
WHOLE POINT OF THE
RESURRECTION?
>> THIS HAS CAUSED -- PEOPLE
LISTENING.
THEY SAID THE ARTICLE IS THE
PART OF HIS RECONSTRUCTION
WHICH THE EXACT WORDS SPOKEN
BY THE POPE ARE NOT QUOTED.
NO QUOTATION MARKS IN THE
ABOVE ARTICLE SHOULD
THEREFORE BE CONSIDERED AS A
FAITHFUL TRANSCRIPTION OF
THE HOLY FATHER'S WORDS.
THAT'S A NON-DENIAL DENIAL.
I MEAN, SO PEOPLE ARE STILL
WONDERING WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN?
>> Laura: INTERPRETATION OF
THE INTERPRETATION.
>> THE LANGUAGE WASN'T
EXACTLY WHAT HE SAID.
BUFF THE QUESTION IS
SUBSUBSTANTIVELY DID HE
CAPTURE WHAT THE POPE MEANT.
>> I DOUBT IT THE POPE HAS
TALKED ABOUT SATAN AND THE
LURES OF THE DEVIL FOR A
LONG TIME.
THEY SHOULD DECRY THIS AND
SAY THE POPE BELIEVES IN
HELL AND THIS IS A BIG
MISFIRE.
>> Laura: WELL, NOW WALMART
IS REMOVING -- WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH TIME.
THEY ARE REMOVING COSMO.
>> THEY DON'T WANT LITTLE